this is water in there
[Music]
God pull this little places
Oh baby
[Music]
Mickey go on the [ __ ] house
these [ __ ] don't know you're gonna
fight yet nothing lesbians again fight
get up [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
let's be showing up to fight
pull the head and Mickey calms down -
shorty crap
he's too busy never seen before mine's
gonna fight the blanket force
that's what recycling so he said today's
they're negotiating for Nene that's good
you could do the fight in September
right you gotta have to show up biggest
eye-roll woman
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
are you kidding me or what [ __ ] three
for twenty get you a life together we're
going deep in the hemisphere of life
tonight so I hope you're prepared if
you're under 18 get off the [ __ ]
periscope [ __ ] you can end up
being a juvenile delinquent they're
gonna send you through the same jail
sleepers as in you gonna have to blow
Kevin Bacon and then gonna come crying
to you uncle Joey no stars at debt
they're enroute tonight we got the TKOs
lee's taken two of these [ __ ] things
tonight what is the stars there whistles
Fozzie you want take some situation yeah
you wanna take a little liquid acid
tonight all [ __ ] yeah it's over tonight
oh [ __ ] people you know what this is
right
oh [ __ ] look at this is turning black in
here this is tremendous here tonight
we're going deep into the murky waters
we got everything set we got blotter and
[ __ ] liquid that's how we're rolling
and we got these and we got all this
[ __ ] I don't know what this is
aizen's a bit brawny those [ __ ]
brownies older than death you want to
play
[Music]
oh [ __ ] we got some dad in this
[ __ ] tonight we got everything
you came on a good night [ __ ] big
sigh yeah we give you a little hint of
this acid you'll never come back oh good
this is who I am here's where this is
Grateful Dead 5 [ __ ] I'm sayin this is
the [ __ ] to kill [ __ ] Aaron Hernandez
this is the [ __ ] that made him forget
the sewers come bother me now this [ __ ]
anyway that's it that's that it's time
for some [ __ ] bombs it's going out
Lee what are you doing your daily thing
you want one of these transmission
fluids you sure the [ __ ] let me take
some deep never comes test you they
don't know what this is
say something [ __ ] the bar machine we're
just gonna suspend Mickey gah we don't
know what he's got at him but it's
something not right I'm saying don't
tell us you want the GNC [ __ ]
there ain't that [ __ ] at GNC I got the
[ __ ] this [ __ ] deadly tonight man
we'll give you a half a piece of [ __ ]
flaw how's that whatever we'll do the
other half so you guys can go back to
the crib tonight I know it's only rock n
roll but I like it
we got to make the house believe send
ikkyo with a perennial right now dick
you want pieces yeah that's transmission
fluid [ __ ] around it's already gonna
bum my man needs a bomb then why bill
needs a bomb we [ __ ] around tonight
they might take it back into the murky
waters the liquids out the sugar cubes
from Jefferson Airplane look at this
[ __ ] we're rocking tonight [ __ ] you
[ __ ] with country I gotta tell you
without me tonight I'm coming over here
I'm minding my own [ __ ] business my
driving records in passing back and
forth I'm one of those dudes I get
pissed off of you don't put a blinker on
I put the blinker on and make the left
there's no parking at the weed store so
I make the u-turn but halfway down the
block there's a stripper having a
boyfriend she steroid it out she's
battling [ __ ] I always pull into that
driveway and there outside she's tatted
up big tits I just do it to look at her
and I come right back to Burbank
Boulevard so as I was making the right
this dummy was making a left but you
know those [ __ ] that golde
inside lane like they try to be cool and
trying to like like he was one of those
guys he sees me coming and he likes
works that's not my fault that's his
[ __ ] fault
I don't say nothing about it I could've
gained a friend I could he yelled I'm in
no mood I pull into the [ __ ] parking
spot a buddy of mine coffee from New
Jersey
and I'm talking to him or son the
[ __ ] family van pulls up next to me
my god wake up one of those chrysler
[ __ ] things and he's looking at me
like eyeballing me when i get out he
goes hey hey he goes when you made that
u-turn before you're gonna hurt me and
my family who are you talking about I
put my blinker on
I made the u-turn you won't even know
I'm in you caught in anything so you
don't understand you know you could have
heard this ago so let me ask you a
question are you okay and he goes yeah
goes your wife okay yeah go then nobody
got hurt obviously I just asked oh you
want a problem you're just one of these
[ __ ] do is I want to [ __ ] that mom I
don't Wednesday night three for twenty
that's that you want to [ __ ] do and
he just looked at me because half the
people in California want to step up to
you but don't you say something back to
them this guy throws like his face
looking froze and I just say no explain
him I didn't hurt his feelings I didn't
say nothing and I just asked them you so
if you're okay and your wife is okay you
came back because you want a problem
is that what you want a problem he don't
know that them remember that bark was
through they sell tacos that's a gay bar
they closed that down but next to it is
it Armenian barbershop I got those guys
I got those guys yeah the liquor store
there's a guy that shows the keys so she
sells my scheme my patches of [ __ ] so I
go in there all the time and I talked to
those Armenians they were outside smoke
their cigarettes those Armenians to come
over that body disappeared that
disappears plus the guys in the lead
slow yeah the guys in the weeks cool
have an apartment in the front and they
play cards they bring girls and there is
[ __ ] Gary little [ __ ] this guy
wanted to start a fight with me yeah but
thank God I just asked him do you want
to [ __ ] prom and I was seriously goes
no no no you know he didn't say no he
just froze Benny and I get this normally
this is why I don't want to live here no
more these [ __ ] people are just a
bunch of gluten eating [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Music]
let's do this piracy now this will put
you on a different planet they don't
love that pattern I love it you ain't
quote we gotta be positive you gotta be
positive
you're not gonna coffee your lungs out
[ __ ] gonna be stronger than that do you
understand which one you look like one
of them bloggers dad is my dad is here
tonight
you know what I want more than anything
is his heavy hair oh thank you sire
the flying tonight oh [ __ ]
we got a full [ __ ] house here tonight
we'll talk about a lot of things tonight
what's going on ladies int that thing
might be stuck a lot of heart a lot of
hard we'll give me that back and I'll
fix the flea
oh [ __ ] there you go
there's deke sigh at balls [ __ ] like
either he don't even give a [ __ ]
Snoop Dogg his helmet give me that
[Music]
this is Joel yeah don't knock her up cuz
that [ __ ] will sue you and then you
have a little Mickey run around La
this'll cost you forty four thousand a
month
these Bunco these white [ __ ] is a
treacherous a yeah
then I like Jersey you could punch him
in the stomach don't say that Jersey
after three months you can punch it with
the stomach you can finish it and they
won't down my one one these [ __ ]
savages leave it on fire let it burn
oh here we go
Lisa at first [ __ ] bunk I'll give
this hold on mama said yes Papa said no
here we go savagery that's my dog right
there yeah guys but it goes [ __ ] yeah
Wednesday 3 420 if you ain't on it you
slip
[Music]
[ __ ] no some black hooker in new for the
small 25 suck the collar off you dick
you know I'm saying you have an hour by
no dick with freckles it was like Dennis
Johnson remember the guard from the
Celtics yeah he was orange on vinyl
black dude right let's try this [ __ ]
this is [ __ ] it's a costly 200 to get
that [ __ ] oh [ __ ] Sam how the [ __ ] I
don't give a damn let's go eat and train
the second you guys show these people
they will be in three stories this is
training [ __ ] day right here this is
Denzel and the other dude with [ __ ]
yellow teeth whoa there you go look at
them cool then you go like a sadness
it's what I'm talking about people it's
three for twenty you ain't got time to
[ __ ] around young day team hang up now
cut this [ __ ] is that type of party
what do you think he sighed thinking
about his life waiting if [ __ ] took you
there for a second that mule is kicking
right now especially when they got money
in the mattress you never seen a dead
Jew when Jews don't die so they get the
first return check yeah that's may go
it's over
we got no [ __ ] penis left how's that
meal today ladies and gentlemen this
[ __ ] play people this is one of the
best bonds I've ever purchased in my 30
[ __ ] years of smoking reefer we
purchased through coz we drop one
we're gonna keep passing this bong
around to this reef is that's a type of
420 with you and this ain't no [ __ ]
hoop-dee-doo movie star reefer
you know and we love purple Express suck
my dick we don't smoke none of that
garbage here this is call [ __ ] dead
star for a reason you understand me how
much is left I don't know it don't
matter when I start the podcast that we
smoke it all we're going back to Jersey
style this [ __ ] come in come
over here is the third round you're
[ __ ] around go oh [ __ ] bill that's
the Jersey Shore boys mess my dog is
sure
cops are coming the cops are coming you
don't know nothing you [ __ ]
don't know nothing you understand me
keep your mouth shut they come to your
house all of me now
look at this [ __ ] we're going deep in
the murky waters knob pull that savage
off oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh yeah people's
going deep if I was you call United get
your plane ticket we're gonna be at
about 11:30 you can make it
call United Tom you're taking a beating
you want to go in first class you want
to get kicked in the head you want to
look like Ronda Rousey [ __ ] it let's do
this [ __ ] [ __ ] you people
everybody huh 420 high times this is
high times the height times off this
ain't doing we're doing you understand
me and now what a pop from sugar cube
Dickie SIA wants to go deep we're not
gonna make him get a [ __ ] plane
ticket and let him down look at leas all
depressed least thinking about tonight
at 4:00 in the morning when he walks to
CVS on Laurel Canyon
[Music]
this is it this is Anthony and villo
style in the shed music reefer don't
make me pop out of [ __ ] cerveza Fria
Tuesday night Wednesday night it don't
matter what matters is you're here
you're alive and kicking you got a plan
and uncle Joey got your back that's all
that [ __ ] matters tellingly don't
just sit there
that's right none bum reefer they can
take a some Vietnam now we're fine let
me get that pipe over there my little
brother it's that type of party tonight
you understand me and if you're under 18
hang up now look who's coming
look who just woke up and it sounds bad
he just came out of [ __ ] seclusion
he's like one look at that's a [ __ ]
weapon in the Jersey Shore down the
shore at a bar on the Saturday that's a
year of doorman with what you want to do
we wanna keep hanging out a little [ __ ]
buddies we went to Starbucks have a
coffee and we smoked the joint listen
listen knock that [ __ ] off you know what
Uncle Joe we know you gotta take it to
the next limit you understand me
at least I at you ready I'm gonna do a
bond and put the liquid acid in the
[ __ ] bong we think about that Lee I'm
gonna make you is wiggle the key sighs
knocking we'll get this podcast started
in ten minutes
one more bond carefully and we'll get
this [ __ ] I mean right now literally
this building is burning down there's no
way they could have a shake the smell of
reefer that we put in this building that
star of Paris
look at Lee taking the chance just like
[ __ ] having Hernandez took a chance
this saying he wrote a [ __ ] thing on
his head like Charles Manson does it
seem like him I smell a [ __ ] rat yeah
some a right there some a right this is
[ __ ] this is called I don't know it's
amicable you gotta live from the church
studio that's right for the mix
they goalie this is this is the monster
mr. [ __ ] there you go that's the one
that killed Kennedy there you go ladies
and gentlemen
who said training is a little you see
I'm saying you guys doubted the mix of
things can you like me these
[ __ ] don't know - bartender
since 1983 understand
I'm telling you everybody's [ __ ] up
it's that time tonight everybody want I
don't even know what the [ __ ] 420 is I
don't know what it stands for and I
really don't give a [ __ ] because in my
life 420 is we've been 420 in it since
[ __ ] since [ __ ] out and first flipped
oh I heard let's most Jersey swamp weed
[Music]
[Music]
This Is It this is how we do it people
we're still weed mechana stirs don't
forget tomorrow perennial I'll be there
at 1:00 o'clock 1:15 for about an hour
we're doing it bigger per any of them
are they got Mexican food tacos Dan
[ __ ] around I gotta go to doctor
first 11:45 to check out my knees and
I'll be on the 405 north after that
coming direct to you [ __ ] all
right we're gonna start this podcast
what is it youtube.com slash c / Joey
Diaz we got my main man yo [ __ ]
thank you right oh yeah justice what do
you want to do it you want you want to
watch modern family you're gonna watch
modern family your [ __ ] girlfriend
and try to [ __ ] under the blanket
or you want to run with some [ __ ]
killers tonight I wanna watch Parks and
Rec you know watching that [ __ ] no more
it's uncle Joey in about ten minutes
they black
[Music]